JOE: Tonight's speaker
is Nataly Kelly.
You may have heard of Nataly.
She is Chief Research Officer
at Common Sense Advisory.
She's been in the Language
Services industry since 1996.
She's fluent in Spanish and
English, and has also studied
French, Italian, German,
Arabic and Japanese.
She's a former Fulbright
scholar in Spanish
sociolinguistics, and has
studied in Ecuador, Ireland,
and the United States.
She is author of "Telephone
Interpreting," the first book
ever written on the topic, and
"Found in Translation: How
Language Shapes Our Lives and
Transforms the World." So
again, if you could hold your
questions till the end, we'll
have Nataly up here to speak.
[APPLAUSE].
NATALY KELLY: My Twitter
handle is @NatalyKelly,
N-A-T-A-L-Y-K-E-L-L-Y. And the
handle for the book is
@xl8book, X-L, number 8,
B-O-O-K. [LAUGHS].
So thank you very much, Joe,
for inviting me here.
And thanks to Ann from Google,
and all of you
for coming out today.
I'm going to talk about
something that I normally
don't get to talk about--
normally, I'm talking
about Common
Sense Advisory research.
And today, I'm actually going to
talk about a book that I've
written with Jost Zetzsche,
who is my co-author.
And the book is called "Found
in Translation." And the
subtitle is, "How Language
Shapes Our Lives and
Transforms the World."
And it's not just a subtitle.
This really means something.
And I'm going to explain why
we chose that subtitle
throughout my talk.
So, a lot of people, when they
think of translation, think
about academic exercises,
and think about literary
translation.
And if they think about
interpreting at all, they tend
to think about conference
interpreting.
Now, how many of you
speak another
language other than English?
Almost everybody.
Wonderful.
Can I get you to shout out
on the count of three the
languages that you speak?
Ready?
One, two, three.
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
NATALY KELLY: Ooh!
And I heard somebody who's
still counting off the
languages back there.
[LAUGHS].
Excellent.
So we have a pretty multilingual
group here today.
And how many of you have
done translation work?
Please raise your hands.
And how many of you have done
paid translation work?
Professional translation work.
How many of you are full-time
professional translators?
And how many of you work in
translation, localization,
internationalization today?
OK.
Great.
So, many of you are familiar
with some of the concepts that
I'm gonna be talking about
today, and some of the stories
that I'll be sharing.
But I'm pretty sure there will
be other stories that you
haven't heard yet that
come from the book.
And hopefully, it will open up
your mind to how big this
field is, and how incredible
the field of
translation really is.
So, the first point that I
really want to make is that
translation shapes our lives.
That's from the subtitle
of the book.
And I don't just mean the people
who work in this field.
I mean everybody's life.
Translation affects every single
person in the world.
That's my premise.
So, I'm going to give you some
stories that come from the
book that show exactly how
translation shapes our lives.
So, the first story is
about this word.
"Intoxicado." Now, how many
of you speak Spanish?
A good number of people
speak Spanish.
Excellent.
So I'm sure all of you know
how to translate this term
perfectly, right?
[LAUGHS]
It's a tricky one.
So, those of you who speak
Spanish, don't give me the
answer, please.
[LAUGHS]
Those of you who don't speak
Spanish, looking at that word,
you probably think that it
means intoxicated, right?
So there was a bilingual
nurse in a Florida
Hospital in the year 1980.
And this bilingual nurse heard
the patient came in and his
family said he was intoxicado.
So, how did he render that
word into English?
He said, he's intoxicated.
There's just one problem.
It doesn't mean intoxicated.
This is a pretty difficult word
to translate on its own.
I can give you some examples,
and you can help me figure out
the meaning.
So "intoxicacion por plomo"
means lead poisoning.
"Intoxicacion por alimentos,"
food poisoning.
"Intoxicacion solar,"
sun poisoning.
So how do you translate the
word "intoxicado"--
he's intoxicado?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NATALY KELLY: Yeah.
But do we say in English that
somebody's poisoned?
We really don't say
that, do we?
We say they have food
poisoning, or
they have sun poisoning.
So it just goes to show how
difficult it is to translate a
single word like that.
Now in this case, what happened
was that he was given
the wrong course of treatment
because of this mistranslated
word, and a healthy young
man became quadriplegic.
Shortly after, a lawsuit
followed, and a $71 million
settlement was the result of
this mistranslation as well.
So this is often known as
the $71 million word.
Right.
So there are consequences to
mistranslating a single term.
Consequences that are important
in terms of the
human value, as well as the
economic and financial
repercussions.
Let me give you another
example that also
comes from the book.
So, this is an example of
something that happened in
Haiti, January 12, 2010.
We remember what
happened then.
This was when the earthquake
took out most of the
communications.
Now, we have a special
guest with us today.
Rob, would you mind
standing up?
So, Rob is a researcher, and
developed a very impressive
system that was able to use the
only form of communication
that was available when
all other forms of
communication went down.
These were text messages
or SMS messages.
So the system that
Rob created--
and his work as a researcher
at Stanford--
was called Mission 4636.
And this system allowed him
to gather more than 1,000
volunteers in 49 countries.
And because of this system, in
the first six weeks after the
earthquake--
or after the program
was launched--
there were more than 40,000
messages that were translated
in 10 minutes or less,
all via text message.
Now, you might think, well,
why would these
text messages matter?
The rescuers who were rescuing
people on the ground spoke
different languages.
Many of them were coming through
international aid and
relief organizations.
So in order for them to reach
people-- in order for them to
find out what was wrong, give
them lifesaving treatment,
help them find shelter, help
them find safety--
those translations
really mattered.
They saved human lives.
They saved hundreds of lives.
So the work that Rob did, and
the work that all those
volunteer translators did,
had a tremendous
impact on human life.
But if you're not convinced yet
that translation shapes
your life, I'll give you
another example.
Because, so far, I've shown you
how translation affects
other people's lives.
So you might be asking, well,
how does it affect me?
Tell me about me.
I care about me.
So here's an example for you.
The Global Public Health
Intelligence Network, also
known as GPHIN, is mining--
constantly--
global news reports, and using
automatic translation
technology to translate
articles
from English and into--
into and out of English and
eight other languages.
So this is machine translation,
automatic
translation.
Now, what you might not know
about this system is that
Swine Flu and SARS--
the first cases--
were detected by this
particular system.
What it's doing is scanning
for important
key words, for symptoms.
For things like fever.
For things like sneezing.
For some of these symptoms that
are the first indicators
of a public health outbreak.
So the system issued alerts in
those cases, and the response
and containment efforts
followed.
So this goes you to show that
translation is behind the
scenes, keeping us safe,
preventing public health
outbreaks from spreading.
How else does translation
shape our lives?
If you're not convinced yet,
I'll give you another
compelling example.
On September 10, 2001--
the day before the
9/11 attacks--
there were some warnings
that were caught.
Warnings that were
issued about what
was about to happen.
So the words "tomorrow is zero
hour" and the words "the match
is about to begin"
were intercepted.
These were recorded and
intercepted from al-Qaeda
operatives by US intelligence
agencies.
Now, there was just
one problem.
These messages were
not in English.
They were in Arabic.
So when do you think they
were translated?
September 12, 2001.
And it's not to say that if
these had been translated on
the day that they were
intercepted, that the 9/11
attacks would have necessarily
been prevented.
Obviously, a lot has to happen
for something to be considered
a credible threat, and
a lot of wheels have
to be put in motion.
But it does go to show the
importance of not only
translation, but translation
that happens quickly.
Translation that can happen
efficiently, systematically.
So this comes from official
US Government documents.
Anyone can look up
this information.
And it's a well-known fact that
the US Government has had
a backlog-- tremendous backlog--
of translation that
hasn't been carried out.
And this is a constant
struggle that the US
Government officials
are still facing.
So, what happens when
countries go to war?
How does translation
play a role then?
Well, translators and
interpreters are constantly
being used when countries come
into conflict with each other.
This is a picture of a man who
everybody needs to know.
Everybody watching needs to
know and remember the
name of this man.
He is one of the true heroes
of the interpreting
profession.
His name is Peter Less.
Now, Peter Less was an
interpreter at the Nuremberg
Trials, where the Nazi war
criminals were tried.
Peter had the difficult task
of rendering testimony, and
rendering the words
of some of the
masterminds of the Holocaust.
This was even more difficult, in
his case, because he was a
Holocaust survivor himself.
In fact, his entire family--
his parents, his siblings,
his grandmother--
were killed in Auschwitz.
So he had to be the voice
of the people who were
responsible for these
atrocities.
Can you imagine how difficult
that must have been?
But yet, he was able to stand
to that task and to carry it
out heroically.
So he is a name who I hope we
will always think of when we
think of why translation
matters in the world.
And again, you may say, this
doesn't affect me.
This is all about
other people.
But when we think about access
to justice, and we think about
carrying out the proceedings
in the legal system,
translation truly does
affect all of us.
If any of us is a victim of a
crime, and the only witness
speaks a language other than
English, do we want to deny
them an interpreter?
Absolutely not.
Even the most pro-English-only
person would want that person
to be able to state
what happened
if they were a victim.
So I think it highlights
the importance of
translation in our world.
But I'm not done.
I'll give you another example.
This is another woman who I
would love you to know.
Her name is Mara Clara Sharupi
Jua, and she is from the Shuar
indigenous group in the
Ecuadorian Amazon.
And she is a poet.
And she's here in this picture
reading some of her poems.
And she writes poems in
Shuar and in Spanish.
And I'm very privileged to be
her translator, to translate
her poetry into English.
Now, you may think, why should
I care, Nataly, about a
translator of a language that
is in the Ecuadorian Amazon?
How does this affect me?
Well, it does affect you.
Because one in every four
ingredients in pharmaceutical
products come from the
Amazon rainforest.
And only between 10 and 20% of
the plants in the Amazon
rainforest have been
categorized.
So, many of the secrets of
healing and powers of curing
diseases are locked up in
languages like the one that
she speaks.
So, if there is a cure for
AIDS, for cancer, for
diabetes, for a lot of
the ails of society--
ailments--
chances are they're there
in the Amazon.
And they're locked up in
languages that translation has
the power to unlock.
So hopefully I've convinced
you now that translation
affects your lives.
Now I'd like to try to convince
you that translation
can be found pretty
much everywhere.
And this is where things
start to get exciting.
So, right now, there is actually
a conference going on
in San Diego at the American
Translators Association.
And the American Translators
Association has
about 11,000 members.
There are about 2,000
people there.
And I just was looking on their
conference website at
some of the sessions that
are happening right now.
So we have sessions going on
right now that deal with
German accounting standards,
patent abstract translation in
French, interpreting proverbs
and idioms in Korean.
Criminal Terminology
in Brazil.
Slang and Taboo for
the Courts.
Translating and Interpreting
War Crimes Trials for
Bosnian/Serbian/Croatian.
Translating Sexist and
Gender-Neutral Language.
Things like understanding the
clinical trials that you're
translating and the
science behind it.
Subtitling Motion Pictures.
Translating for Design and
Construction in Israel.
Advancing Productivity Using
Voice Recognition.
And one of my personal
favorites, Building Your Own
Statistical Machine Translation
Systems.
Very interesting that there is
a session that is to teach
translators how to build
their own systems.
So you can see that translation
is in all kinds of
different places.
And in the book, we talk about
translation of Harlequin
romance novels--
something light-hearted--
but translation also of holy
books and sacred texts, which
isn't so light-hearted.
A much more serious topic.
Translators and interpreters
are used in outer space by
astronauts to communicate with
engineers on the ground who
speak other languages.
And--
on another lighthearted note--
if you go to the opera, you
might be handled a libretto that
has been translated so
that you can understand
what it says.
Translators are out there
helping come up with exact
wording for peace treaties,
so that both sides
will agree to them.
And they're also translating
video games.
And translators are also
enabling us to use social
media platforms, which can be
used for fun, and also for
more serious things.
Like revolutions, enabling
people to connect, enabling
people to communicate
and organize.
So, my next important point that
we make throughout the
book is that translation
isn't easy.
Everybody here who has done that
can probably attest to
the fact that that's true.
So, a lot of people who are
working in this field have
this question.
Well, if I'm bilingual, can
I become a translator?
[LAUGHS]
We've all been asked
that, right?
But the best way to answer that
question, I think, is
that not everybody who knows
how to write can be a
professional writer.
Just because you cook dinner
every night doesn't make you a
professional chef.
Just because you drive
a car doesn't
make you Mario Andretti.
The same thing is true
for translators.
Just because you know two
languages does not make you a
professional translator.
And the proof that we also
have to offer people that
translation isn't so easy
is that when people take
professional translation exams,
the passing rates are
usually very low--
around 20% for most exams for
translators and interpreters.
So of 8 out of 10 bilingual
individuals who are failing
these tests.
That goes to show that it takes
more than just fluency
in two languages to
be a translator.
The reason for that is
because, of course,
words can be tricky.
They can be misunderstood.
They can be misconstrued.
They can be taken
out of context.
And that's just in
one language.
All we have to do is just
think of the classic
"telephone" game, where one
person whispers to the next,
to the next, to the next.
And by the end of it, we get a
completely transformed message.
And that's just in
one language.
Language also never
stops evolving.
It is completely unique
to each person.
My husband sent out an email
blast to a bunch of people to
let them know about the book.
And he wrote, apologies
for the spousal spam.
And I thought, oh, a new term.
OK, where did he get this?
So I asked him, where
did you hear that?
And he said, oh, I
just made it up.
That's just one example
of human creativity.
We come up with new terms
all the time.
We coin new terms
And that's why humans are so
necessary for translation.
But when we think about
spoken language,
it's much more complex.
Obviously we have things like
tone of voice to worry about.
We have accent and
pronunciation.
We even have things like
volume levels.
And, of course, translation of
spoken language interpretation
is affected by other things that
aren't necessarily within
our control.
So we have the equipment
that we're using.
We have less predictable things
like background noise,
interference.
Even if someone has a sore
throat, that can affect our
ability to comprehend them.
So there's all these other
variables that can interfere
with an interpreter's ability
to render information
accurately.
So when we start to talk about
more than one language--
we say in the book that
languages are like different
instruments.
They have different scales.
They have different sounds.
Sometimes they don't even
have the same notes.
You can't physically play the
same note in the same range or
the same octave on
one instrument
as you can on another.
So we actually wrote in the book
that poetry translation
is like playing a piano
sonata on a trombone.
And I really think that's true,
because I'm currently
trying to translate some poetry
that was originally
written in Shuar.
And to get that to come
into English is a
pretty mighty challenge.
I would also say it's not just
poetry translation that
presents this problem.
How many of you saw in the
recent debates the Romney
quote that's been everywhere--
binders full of women.
[LAUGHTER].
NATALY KELLY: OK.
How do you translate that?
[LAUGHS]
It's not so easy to translate.
So I wonder how this was
translated in the news for
international media.
But to make it even more
complicated, after this all
came out, I saw an
image that was
shared, and it had Beyonce.
And it said, if you like it,
then you better put three
rings on it.
And it was referring to
a three-ring binder.
And I thought, this is a
translator's nightmare.
Because not only do you have
to know something about
Beyonce, you have to know
something about current events
in American politics.
You have to know about gender
relations and these things
that are happening in the news
with regard to women and
women's rights.
And you have to know that, in
the United States, people use
three-ring binders, which aren't
necessarily used in
every country.
Other countries have two-ring
binders, or four-ring binders,
or six-ring binders.
So it's very complicated to try
to migrate that concept
and that humor, especially
into another language.
Terminology knowledge is
another reason that
translation is difficult.
The average person uses about
4,000 to 5,000 words in
English on a regular basis.
People who are educated--
who've received a basic
education--
between 8,000 and
10,000 words.
The professions that use the
widest vocabularies use more
than double that amount
of words.
So how many words you think
translators have to know?
Well, many of them are crossing
many disciplines, and
many are going into more than
one language, so they are
obviously have to know this kind
of vocabulary in at least
two languages.
So to give you another example
of why translation is so
difficult, I thought I
would show you this.
So, numbers don't need
translation, right?
You can just transfer
them across
languages with no problem.
Right?
[LAUGHS]
Does anyone know what these
numbers have in common, aside
from the fact that they're
on signs, these images?
How about if I show you this?
Does anyone want to volunteer to
take Flight 666 and sit in
seat number 13?
These are bad luck numbers
in this culture, right?
But they might not be bad luck
numbers in every culture.
And all the numbers up here are
bad luck in some culture.
So you can't just transfer
these numbers when you're
translating a marketing
campaign, an advertising
campaign, or maybe even
a flight number.
To give you another example of
how difficult translation can
be, I thought I would tell you
this little story about
President Carter.
So President Carter, when
he was in office, became
accustomed to working
with interpreters.
And after he left office, he
went to Japan, and he was
giving a talk at a school.
And since he had worked with
interpreters many times
throughout his career, he
thought, OK, I'm gonna use a
joke, but I know it's really
hard to interpret jokes.
So I'm gonna make it short.
I'm gonna keep it as a pretty
easy, short joke.
So he told this joke, and the
audience erupted in laughter
after the interpreter rendered
it into Japanese.
They just died laughing.
And he thought, wow.
This is the best response.
I've ever had to a joke.
I wonder what the interpreter's
secret is?
So he went up to the interpreter
and asked-- and at
first she didn't want to say.
But then, he asked again, and
the interpreter said, "Mr.
President, I told the audience,
President Carter
told a funny story.
Everyone must laugh."
[LAUGHTER].
Made the interpreter's
life easier.
It isn't easy to translate
humor, even if you're a
professional interpreter.
So you can see how hard
translation and
interpreting can be.
Now I'd like to talk a little
bit about the future.
I believe that translation
is going to lead
us into a new era.
What do I mean by that?
So I started to look in history
for other professions
that have made a dramatic
impact on the world.
And one of the professions
that came up
was this guy here.
Blacksmiths.
So, in a certain time period,
blacksmiths were seen kind of
like magicians.
They could do magical things.
They could transform metal--
a hard surface-- and soften
it, and make it look
beautiful, and do really
important things with it.
In fact, many people in villages
would come to them,
and they were doing all
kinds of things.
Not only creating every
single nail--
I mean, it's hard to imagine
we couldn't just go
buy a box of nails.
Each one had to be
hand crafted.
But they were doing things
like dental work, and
veterinary work, and all
kinds of things.
Even warming the bread
and baking the
bread for the villages.
Because they were some of the
few people who knew how to
keep fires going.
So, blacksmiths played a
very important role.
And they're-- much like
translators, their work
touched all different
aspects of society.
They were actually the lynchpin
of progress for the
Industrial Revolution.
As needs became more complex,
so did the skills that were
needed by blacksmiths.
And they were actually involved
in helping build the
machines that would eventually
replace their role.
And they gave rise to a new way
of life, a new economy, a
new society.
A whole new way of life.
And that role actually evolved
into many other professions
that did not exist previously
in history.
So, things like welders,
machinists, pipefitters.
And there were also a lot of
blacksmiths that went on to
invent great things using
their skills and their
knowledge, like Studebaker,
John Deere, Henry Ford.
These were all blacksmiths.
So even after their role was
transformed, they continued to
make major contributions.
So, I want to talk--
I'm gonna come back to the
idea of blacksmiths and
translators and what they
have in common.
But the question that you're
probably asking is-- because
blacksmiths kind
of faded away--
does that mean translators are
also going to fade away?
Well, here's where I think
there's a difference between
what blacksmiths did and what
translators are doing.
So the big question is--
that everybody
asks me all the time--
is will human translators
be replaced?
I think when you compare them
to blacksmiths, you can ask
people to use identical nails,
you can standardize things
like railroad ties.
But can you ask people to
use identical words?
Can you ask everybody to
speak the same way?
Can you ask people to mass
produce content?
Can it be like a factory
assembly line?
How much content can
be mass produced?
And how much has to
be customized?
So, let's take a look at what
some of the data says.
So, some of the stats I'm gonna
show you here come from
Common Sense Advisory.
So, the market today
is worth more than
$33 billion US dollars--
the market for language services
and technology.
That's as of 2012.
And the market is growing
at a rate of 12.17%.
Now, the market has continued
to grow steadily throughout
the recession.
Unlike many industries, this
market has continued to grow.
Now, the growth did slow down
a bit during the global
economic downturn.
But it continued to grow, and
historically has always grown
yearly in double-digit
growth rates.
There are more than 26,000
translation agencies or
companies offering translation
services throughout the world.
And our estimates tend to be
pretty conservative compared
to some of the other government
estimates
that are out there.
So, North America is not the
only important area of the
world when it comes
to translation.
In fact, it's not even
the biggest.
Europe is quite a bit larger,
and North America makes up
less than a third.
But translation is a global
industry, as you can see here.
And the dynamics and the
distribution of how this
market is changing are different
every single year
that we look at it.
Asia is rising.
We're seeing North America
play less of a
role than in the past.
So, these things are changing
year by year.
But this market is made up of
many, many services, not just
translation.
Obviously, software
localization--
which a lot of you are
interested in--
on-site interpreting, website
globalization, multimedia
localization--
all of these are encompassed
within this broader market.
But translation is by far the
biggest service, because it's
used by pretty much every type
of organization that
you can think of.
Demand for translation
is growing.
We did a study of Fortune 500
companies, and the vast
majority told us that their
translation volumes have
increased, and that
they expect them
to continue to increase.
Their content volumes
were increasing at
an even faster pace.
So the potential demand for
translation is enormous.
Some studies show that there are
2.5 quintillion bytes of
data-- of information--
coming into existence
every single day.
Translation providers are
converting a tiny, tiny
fraction of that--
0.00000067%.
That's how much they are
converting every day.
So, if even just a tiny fraction
of that information
is useful for translation
purposes, that signifies
enormous potential
for translation.
What a lot of people don't
realize, when they talk about
machine translation replacing
humans, is that human
translators already use
translation software and
translation technology.
And the idea of leveraging
past content is already
widespread.
This is something that has
exists for decades.
So the average translation
agency translates about 43,000
words per day.
And freelancers have an average
of a little less than
2,700 words per day.
We asked freelancers and
translation agencies, how many
words are brand new words
translated for the first time
without using any translation
memory software?
The rate for both was
almost identical.
It's about 60%, which means
that 40% of what they're
translating is using translation
memory--
is relying on past translation
work that's already been done
in the past.
So when we talk about
technology replacing
translation, think about
these figures.
Technology already is helping
replace about 40% of the human
translation work that used
to be done in the past.
It's just being done by a
slightly different technology
than automatic translation.
So, is technology going to
replace human translators?
This is a question we get
asked all the time.
And I always ask, has accounting
software made
accountants obsolete?
Has medical diagnostic software
made doctors obsolete?
Has legal software made
lawyers obsolete?
So, why do we think that
translation software would
make translators obsolete?
Especially when we've been
using translation
software for decades.
That's a question that I think
all of us should ask.
These fields are constantly
evolving, and so is the field
of translation.
And as I mentioned, those 26,000
companies, they're not
just made up of translators.
They're made up of salespeople,
they're made up
of marketing directors, they're
made up of software
engineers, they're made up of
all kinds of people-- human
resources staff.
Many, many people are employed
in this industry.
It's not just translators that
would have to be replaced.
Language is categorized as the
epitome of human intelligence.
So, how many of you are familiar
with the Turing test?
Many of you.
So the Turing test looks at the
machine's ability to use
language as a human would.
And this is considered to be the
ultimate test of whether
machines can have human
intelligence.
So, the questions that we can
ask ourselves when it comes
to, can a machine replace
a human translator?
Can a machine use language
like a human can?
Can a machine debate politics?
Can a machine write poetry?
Can a machine flirt
with someone?
Can a machine tell jokes?
In just one language,
can a machine do
any of those things?
Maybe we can get to a point
where a machine can do some of
those things in one language,
but we're not just dealing
with one language.
We're dealing with thousands
of languages.
So the answer that we need to
remember, when we're asked
this question of can machines
replace humans in translation,
is that we still have
a long way to go.
A really long way.
Google Translate is available
today in 65
languages plus English.
But there are between 6,000
and 7,000 languages in the
world today.
And there's just one big problem
when it comes to
thinking about extending Google
Translate into all of
those languages.
Only 2,261 have writing
systems.
The rest of them are
spoken or signed.
There are hundreds of
sign languages.
There are 18 in Latin
America alone.
So written translation
is really not enough.
It's hardly sufficient.
The majority of the languages
are spoken or signed.
So, even if we could address
all of those issues, and we
can imagine that we can do
automatic translation for
spoken, and written, and signed
language-- and all of
those languages--
there's one more problem.
We would have to hit a big Pause
button on human language
development.
We would say, freeze,
everybody!
No more jokes.
No more plays on words.
No more new invented terms.
Everybody has to stop.
And we are going to mine all
text ever produced in every
single language.
And we are going to analyze
all language variations
currently spoken by every
human being on Earth.
And then we're going to
translate it into and out of
6,000 to 7,000 languages that
exist throughout the world.
As soon as we hit that Play
button again, the need for
human translators returns.
So, this is an image of a
blacksmith that I took just a
couple of years ago, in a very
small town in rural Illinois,
near where I grew up--
in New Salem, which is a
Lincoln Heritage site.
And this is a working
blacksmith.
I was surprised to learn that
there are still about 11,000
working blacksmiths in the
United States today, similar
to the number of professional
translators that are members
of the American Translators
Association.
Now, not all of them are
full-time blacksmiths that are
paid to do that work.
And a lot of what they're doing
is custom work, custom
forging for--
making little brackets to hang
curtains and doorknobs and
things like that.
A lot of that work is very
artisanal, very specialized,
very customized.
But some of them
do still exist.
As I mentioned, many of
the blacksmiths--
this field evolved, the
profession evolved, just like
the profession of translation
is evolving.
But some still do this work the
very same way that it was
done many, many years ago.
So, do translators really have
anything in common with
blacksmiths?
Well, translators don't
work in total
isolation, like I mentioned.
They're not separate from
all of these other jobs.
They are part of an ecosystem,
part of a community.
And it's unlikely that we will
ever be able to mass produce
content the way that you can
mass produce a box of nails in
a standard way.
And as I mentioned, 40% of
current translation work
leverages past work already.
So, if we are in a process of
replacing human translators--
we're already in the midst
of that process--
60% of the work that translators
are doing today
still entails custom forging,
if we want to use the
blacksmith metaphor.
So, this profession is already
in the midst of evolving.
So, are translators the
new blacksmiths?
Well, I believe that much like
blacksmiths pushed us into the
industrial age, into the
Industrial Revolution,
translation is pushing us past
the information age and we are
moving now into the information
transformation age.
Whatever shape the next
revolution we have takes--
a lot of people have referred
to this as the Information
Revolution--
translation has to
play a part.
We can't talk about access to
information unless we talk
about translation, unless
we talk about
the language component.
So translation will be critical
in helping us achieve
a better quality of life.
Now, we did a study recently
at Common Sense Advisory on
the need for translation
in Africa.
And this was a study that was
commissioned by Translators
Without Borders.
And we were surprised to see
that so many respondents told
us that translation would effect
virtually every aspect
of their life.
Political inclusion, health
information, information about
how to prevent conflict.
People even said that they
thought it would reduce-- more
access to translated information
would reduce
violent conflict.
They also said that it would
prevent the loss of life, of
loved ones.
Just having information
to basic--
access to basic information
about how to prevent certain
health concerns and health
conditions would have had a
tremendous impact.
So when we think about the
Industrial Revolution, how it
led us to a new quality of life,
I truly believe that
translation, for many people who
don't have much access to
information, especially in their
native languages, can
definitely impact their lives.
We have data that
shows us this.
I don't think that content
is king anymore.
I believe that the ability
to transform content, to
intelligently use that
information, to customize it,
is truly the new king
or maybe queen.
Speaking of kings, I was
looking for stories and
information about blacksmiths,
and I came across this story
about King Arthur.
So, King Arthur summoned all the
artisans and asked them to
explain why their work was
important to building Camelot.
He asked them to justify
their position.
So he brought in the tailor, he
brought in the carpenter,
he brought in the
stonemason, the
goldsmith, and other artisans.
And each of them made a very
strong case to him for why
their work was important.
And he asked them where
they got their tools.
And each one of them said,
the blacksmith.
So Arthur asked the
blacksmith, and
who makes your tools?
And the blacksmith said, Sire,
I make my own tools.
That is my craft.
Now, remember that American
Translators Association
session that I pointed out,
where translators are being
taught to create their own
statistical machine
translation engines?
Talk about making
your own tools
Is that our craft?
Is that the craft of translators
for the future?
"And the kindly King moved the
humble blacksmith to the head
of his table, as he had made
all the tools for all the
trades." I truly believe that
translators are in the process
of making their own information
tools, whether
that is contributing to their
own translation memory
databases, or simply producing
translations that are being
mined by statistical machine
translation engines.
And these are tools that can
truly open up a door to human
rights and to a civilization
that we can't
even describe today.
We haven't even imagined what
it will be like for so many
people who don't have access
to information, and can't
understand what it's like to
benefit from that information
in a language that they
can truly understand.
So, I've told you about the
book and the fact that I
believe that translation not
only shapes our lives and
transforms the world, but I also
believe that translation
truly defines our future.
I think when we talk about
access to information, we
really have to think about
access to information as a
human right.
And until we can unlock that
information for those 6,000 to
7,000 languages, we truly are
not providing equal access to
everybody who needs it.
So that's why I believe
translation matters, and
that's why I believe it will
have an important effect on
the way we live our lives.
Not only today, but
in the future.
So, with that, I will be happy
to take your questions
[APPLAUSE].
MALE SPEAKER: So, I think I want
to put together a couple
thoughts, because you covered
a lot of ground.
But the 6,000 to 7,000
languages--
I think that includes
a fair number of
dead and archaic languages?
NATALY KELLY: No.
Those are all languages that are
spoken, but many of them
are endangered.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
NATALY KELLY: Mm-hmm.
MALE SPEAKER: Also, the
statistics that are based on
the volume of translation, a lot
of that is driven by the
amount of content that's being
translated, not necessarily
the demands.
Because I think most of us in
this room know that we have a
number of companies that like
to just translate whatever
there have gotten, don't always
pay attention to the
quality of their content,
and so forth.
I see pressure in
many countries--
China, India--
as a part of solving--
and also in Africa--
solving their literacy issues
and their communication issues
by moving towards--
well, first, education, but then
also standardization and
centralization of their
population's ability to speak
fewer languages.
Moving in that direction.
So, between that and the number
of languages that are
dying every year, it would seem
that there's also a trend
that is somehow ignored in
your discussion of having
actually fewer working
languages in
the world over time.
Not that translation
would go away.
But you can't just use the
numbers that are based on
content and costs--
cost demand.
So I wonder if you'd address
some of those points.
NATALY KELLY: Sure.
So, this is a common question
that we're asked a lot.
Are global languages
taking over and
making some of those--
language number 2,497
and so on--
less important?
Because more people can
use an interlanguage--
one of these large
global languages.
What is happening is that a
lot of communities now can
communicate much more easily
than they could in the past.
So, yes, there is a push for
literacy, even in languages
that don't have a
writing system.
And there's this-- in my view--
archaic desire to force
literacy upon people,
when in some cases
that's not that necessary.
If they can communicate with
video-based, audio-based
information, why do they
need to be forced to
have a writing system?
Maybe it's better to use audio
and video information, where a
lot more nuance and a lot more
information-- it's much richer
information to begin with.
So maybe they can
skip that step.
It used to be that writing was
very important, because that
was a fast way to disseminate
lots of information.
But now we can do the same thing
much more efficiently,
in a lot of ways, with
video information.
So one thing that we do at
Common Sense Advisory is look
at the stats of languages on
the web, and which ones are
becoming more important.
Every year we do a large-scale
study on this.
And one thing that we're
noticing is that these less
common languages are becoming
more and more
important each year.
And we have that long tail of
languages effect that I'm sure
many of you are familiar with.
So, yes, there are efforts in
many countries to standardize.
And there are efforts to kind
of go toward one language,
gravitate toward a language of
power, a language that is
traditionally the language of
people in society that are
usually the ones who
hold the resources.
But there are also a lot of
efforts to preserve native
languages, and to allow people
to use the language that's
most familiar to them.
So, I don't think that that
trend is going to go away.
I think it's only going
to increase.
Because all of the companies--
I know many of you work for
large global companies--
and who are you competing with
when you're going into some of
those markets?
You're competing with
local competitors,
for the most part.
And a lot of them are founded
by people who speak some of
those minority languages.
And many of them will have
bilingual websites, and
websites in some of
those languages.
So, every country is slightly
different, of course, with
regard to their language policy,
and with regard to
their preferences, and with
regard to who's in power at
the moment.
But I see a lot of small
languages fighting.
And I see a lot of them
creating content.
And really, if they have the
operating systems to be able
to create content, that is what
is opening the door for
them to be able to do that, at
least in a digital fashion.
So I'm not sure I answered your
question exactly, but
it's a complicated one.
[LAUGHS]
You have a follow up?
MALE SPEAKER: Nataly, oh--
I just lost the mic.
NATALY KELLY: Oh, OK.
[LAUGHS].
MALE SPEAKER: Nataly, thank
you for that presentation.
NATALY KELLY: Thanks, Dex.
MALE SPEAKER: It was very
thoughtful and actually
elegant, in my opinion.
So thank you.
My question is about the term
"translator." When you talk
about translator, can you give
us some thoughts on community?
Is it an individual person?
Is it a community?
And what do these generative
creative types--
what's the profile?
NATALY KELLY: Mm-hmm.
Well, this is a complicated
question.
I just wrote an article on this
exact topic, about how
translators are defining
themselves, and the reality
is, even the lay public will
call an interpreter a
translator.
And even someone who works in
transcreation is usually
referred to as a translator,
even if what they're doing
really isn't translation.
So, the word translation--
I've used this term in this
presentation, because I have
been using the overarching term
related to transferring
information from one language
into another.
And that's the basic definition
that you'll find in
most dictionaries.
What we're finding is-- in some
of the studies that we're
doing at Common Sense
Advisory--
is that this word, and what
it means, is changing
drastically.
So we just a recent
study on pricing.
And the big finding was that
the price of translation--
average price of translation
has dropped.
Nobody likes to hear that.
Don't shoot the messenger.
Well, maybe some people do like
it, if you're buying a
translation.
But nobody on the supply side
likes to hear that.
But what we found is that the
reason for that is that this
field is becoming
more diverse.
So now--
it used to be many years ago,
if you bought translation by
the word, you would get
translation, editing and
proofing including
in the price per
word, included in that.
Now if you buy translation,
you're only getting
translation from a lot of
vendors, and you're separately
paying for editing, and you're
separately paying for
proofing, and you're separately
paying for
translation memory management.
And you're separately paying for
hosting your translation
memory files in perpetuity.
You're separately paying for
terminology management.
You're separately paying
for project management.
Many of these things are
being broken up now.
So the field is getting more
diverse in many senses.
And buyers are starting to
pay separately for that.
So it's not necessarily
that the price
is dropping on average.
It's that many more things
are being built in--
were-- used to be built into
that price per word that
aren't any more.
So there's a lot that goes into
that word translation.
And we're tracking that.
And we actually are doing a
study on production models, to
see how different language
service providers are managing
that process.
And now, we're starting
to see more
collaborative forms emerge.
I talked to a language service
provider the other day, and
they told me that they don't
have a TEP process-- a
Translate, Edit,
Proof process.
What they're doing
is they have two
translators who work together.
Neither--
there's no hierarchy.
They're a pair, kind of like
pair programming, and they are
pair translating.
They are truly pair translating,
and working as a
team, and translating
together.
And so they both have to be
comfortable with the output.
They both have to be comfortable
with the quality.
But it saves them the quality
assurance steps, because
they're doing it from the start
and they're doing it
together, and they're allowing
collaboration.
And all of you are probably
familiar with crowdsource
translation, community
translation.
We've written a ton
about that.
That's another form that's less
common, but is still a
form that is changing the
way we view translation.
Yes.
MIKE: My--
sorry.
My name's Mike.
Thank you for your time, and
it was a very interesting
presentation.
I just have a quick question.
It's pretty basic, actually.
Does highly technical language,
such as legalese or
medical jargon, change
as quickly
as colloquial language?
And if so, in your research,
have you found it easier--
or even possible-- to
standardize that content?
As opposed to humor and other
things like intoxicado as you
mentioned early on in
your presentation.
NATALY KELLY: That type of
terminology tends to evolve
even more quickly.
It depends on the field.
But I recently was at a
conference for the World Bank,
and I was mentioning that the
standard rate of productivity
for translators for decades--
since I entered the profession
at least-- was always 2,500
words per day.
And the translators from the
World Bank told me, well, our
guideline is about 2,000 words
per day, because we have to
translate all kinds of new
financial terminology that's
being invented on the fly, and
new program names, new offices
that are being created in
different countries, and
things like that.
So, it really depends
on the field.
But that kind of terminology
does really represent a
challenge for translators,
because many times they are
inventing the terms and
in another language.
So it takes a lot of research.
It takes how can I come up with
the perfect word for this
that's going to be used from
now on by this official
government body like
the World Bank?
So, that kind of terminology--
and in some fields--
and it depends on
the language as well.
Because some languages have
pretty strict rules about new
terminology entering
the language, at
least in written form.
And they tend to be a little
bit less responsive to what
people are actually using on the
ground, if they have all
those kinds of bodies dictating
what people
can and can't say.
So you can kind of tell what
side I'm on when it comes to
those kinds of organizations.
But it depends on
many factors.
But the short answer is that the
specialized groups tend to
evolve their specialized
areas more quickly.
MALE SPEAKER: In the course of
looking at scenarios for
companies that have several
target languages--
NATALY KELLY: Mm-hmm.
MALE SPEAKER: Did you look
into any interest in
simplified or pivot English
as a intermediate step?
And can you comment on that?
NATALY KELLY: Yeah.
Well, we haven't looked
specifically at pivot English
or simplified English.
But we have looked at English
as a pivot language.
So for those of you who are not
familiar, what's happening
is, because the volume of
translation has been
increasing for a lot of
languages and the translation
profession has not evolved
that quickly in some
countries--
China is one example.
India is another.
What's happening is a lot of
companies have to translate
into English first and
then into Chinese.
So there aren't enough
translators between, say,
Italian and Chinese.
So they're going Italian into
English, English into Chinese.
And this is happening for
other languages as well.
So yes, we have looked
at that.
And it's problematic
for many reasons.
One, the cost of doing that
is twice as expensive.
And second, the quality degrades
when you have to
translate a translation.
So that is a concern.
We've written quite
a bit about that.
And it is a problem.
But what we've written about
is that the fields--
the professions--
are not maturing fast enough.
They're not keeping up.
And it's a difficult problem.
Because, in markets like
China, when I talk to
companies in China, they tell
me, well, if I find someone
who has good enough English to
be a translator, or good
enough German or French, they
go and specialize in
international business, where
they can make more money.
And some translation agencies in
China actually told me that
they can't keep translators long
enough, because some of
them will work for a few months,
they make enough money
that they go on vacation for a
couple months, and then they
never come back.
And then they go work for
a different agency.
And others are saying that they
can't find enough talent
that's willing to work for the
wages that they can offer,
because their standards are
higher, and their customers
expect better quality.
So, it is a real challenge.
We're seeing that for
many different
languages around the world.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hey.
NATALY KELLY: Hey.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can you share
with us the most interesting
or surprising reaction you've
had to your book?
NATALY KELLY: [LAUGHS]
You know, that's a
good question.
I think the most surprising
reaction I've had--
well, there's a few things
that-- there are a few that
come to mind.
I think the most interesting
thing was speaking at the
Jimmy Carter Library.
And a lot of people came to that
who had no background in
translation whatsoever.
In fact, it's kind of a treat
for me to speak to people who
actually deal with translation,
understand a lot
about translation.
In that group-- in most of the
public talks and signings that
I've been doing--
a lot of people are coming just
from the general public.
People in the bookstore
who just wander over.
And I think that's
really exciting.
It has been surprising for me
how many people are interested
in the topic.
And one person actually told me
that they found a copy of
my book in a Barnes and Noble
in Louisville, Kentucky
[LAUGHS], and that really
made me happy.
Because I think the message that
we need to get out is to
all the people who don't work
in languages, and all the
people who are mono-lingual and
don't know a thing about
all other languages.
If they can start to take an
interest and start to see that
translation affects their lives,
I think there'll be a
lot more support for
the industry.
And in writing this book, our
big goal was to really make it
like Freakonomics
for translation.
You know, take a topic that
people think is dry and boring
and not really--
doesn't really affect me, and
to make it fun and exciting,
and make it seem real, and make
it seem like it affects
their lives, because it does.
[LAUGHS].
So, I don't have any
real shockers.
But that's pretty much my
impressions so far.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: That reminds me.
It's not a surprise, but I
noticed one of your most
recent Tweets that you got
a thank-you letter from
President Carter and Rosalynn
for your nice memories of them
in the book.
NATALY KELLY: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: That was--
NATALY KELLY: That was-- well,
I guess that was a shock.
Yes.
That was my big shock.
I'm still a little shaking
when I think about that.
I didn't expect to receive
a letter from
President Carter himself.
I did a whole talk at the
Library about what he had done
throughout his administration,
his short time before he was
involuntarily retired,
as he puts it.
And he actually did a lot for
language access, and did a lot
for the deaf community in the
United States, and a lot for
court interpreting, and
lots of different
areas of language access.
So--
MALE SPEAKER: A nice man.
His mom was nice, too.
Ms. Lillian.
NATALY KELLY: Aww.
[LAUGHS].
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, thank
you for the talk.
You already addressed
this somewhat,
but I have a question.
Do you know Duolingo?
Duolingo is a new technology.
It's very, very innovative.
It combines language learning
and crowdsourced translation.
Do you think these kind of new
technologies can change how
translation is done?
NATALY KELLY: Well, I have not
talked with the developers of
Duolingo personally.
But I have been watching what
they're doing, and all of us
on the research team at Common
Sense Advisor are constantly
taking briefings from technology
vendors, and
tracking what's going on with
products like Duolingo.
And I think it's interesting.
You know?
I think it's interesting
what they're doing.
And a lot of companies are
doing very interesting
things right now.
What I think is even more
interesting than what they're
doing with their technology is
the fact that they're getting
funding for some of
these things.
So, we're starting to see a lot
of high-tech startups that
are attracting interest from
investors and venture capital.
And I think that is very
interesting, because I haven't
really seen the business case
being proved for a lot of
these things yet.
But what I'm interested in is
the fact that this is raising
awareness in society at large.
So, Ashton Kutcher is a backer
of Duolingo, and Tim Ferris.
And we wrote a post recently
on our blog about all the
celebrities that are backing
translation technologies.
You know, Gene Simmons from Kiss
is a backer of Ortsbo.
And many people don't realize
that Bono has interest in a
company called SDI Media--
which some of you might be
familiar with, if you work in
film and gaming.
And they do a lot of the
multilingual subtitling of
voiceovers.
So this kind of interest from
high-profile names and venture
capital, and actually seeing
some real money come into the
industry is, I think,
of great interest.
And I'll be very interested
to see if those investors
actually make a profit and
to see what happens.
This particular model--
a hybrid of language learning
and translation--
is interesting.
I have been monitoring what's
happening, and we'll see.
I try to be open-minded when it
comes to any new innovation
like this, because we are
independent and we kind of
have to stand back and see
what's happening from a
broader market perspective.
So we can't be tied to
any old-fashioned
ways of doing things.
We're always looking at, OK,
what are the newest trends?
And how is this going to
shake up the industry?
So, we'll see what happens
with Duolingo.
There's certainly a lot
of buzz about it.
They're doing a good
job with marketing.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
Mm-hmm?
MALE SPEAKER: Your discussion
about the Beyonce picture
illustrated very interestingly
the amount of context required
to understand something.
Do you have any analogous
examples from your Shuar
poetry translation as to what
kind of contextual differences
would need to be explained?
NATALY KELLY: Oh.
Too many to list.
I mean, her culture is so
different from the one that I
grew up in.
And there's a single word in
her language that actually
means "the song that is emitted
through the fragrance
of a plant." "The song that is
emitted through the fragrance
of a plant." And I have to think
about it every time I
say it, because it still
confuses me.
So that's in one of her poems.
And I had to figure out how on
Earth to render that into
English without destroying the
lyrical quality of the poem.
[LAUGHS]
So I went with--
I went around with "sacred song"
and all these different
things, and it just
doesn't convey it.
So we ended up putting an
asterisk and an explanation at
the bottom.
[LAUGHS]
Because it's the only
way to give the full
context to the reader.
But yeah, there are
many like that.
But we don't even have to go
to a language like Shuar to
come up with examples
like that.
There are tons of examples
like this in all kinds of
languages, even languages
like Spanish.
There are words--
and we have a whole example
in the book of words
for brown in Spanish.
And it depends on if you're
describing a bear, or an
animal, or eyes, or hair.
What word do you
use for brown?
And people have asked me, does
that mean that people who
speak Spanish see shades
of brown that other
people don't see?
Maybe that's one
of the weirdest
questions that I got, Mary.
[LAUGHS]
But it is fascinating to think
about all of these different
concepts that we have that are--
even in languages that
are not linguistically that
distant from each other.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you very
much for the talk.
I had one question.
When you were explaining how
much power the translators
have, especially for translators
at the UN, or who
translate for political
issues--
I was wondering if there were
any ways for citizens to find
out afterwards if the
translators had
any doubt, or any--
were wondering.
Like, here, I wasn't
really sure.
And this could lead
to potential--
yeah, yeah.
So I was wondering, were the
tools available for that?
NATALY KELLY: Oh, yeah.
Well, it's very hard.
There are tons of examples that
we mention in the book.
I'll give you one famous one.
The words "we will bury you"
that were spoken by Nikita
Khrushchev were seen
as a threat.
And people thought that he
literally meant we want to
kill you, we want to bury you
with a nuclear attack.
And the phrase that he was
using actually was a more
common phrase at that time in
Russian that meant something
like, we will be here even
when you are gone.
We will outlast you.
And people have asked me, well,
are you sure that's
really what that meant?
And I have given examples of
things we say in English, like
"he came in dead last."
Or, "oh, you're killing
me," when
someone's making you laugh.
If you think about how we
translate those things, they
could have a similar impact if
they were mistranslated.
As for how to go back and find
out if that's exactly what
someone said, it's a
really hard thing.
Because you've probably
seen in the media,
even in recent times.
When a mistranslation is out
there, that's the story.
What that person said, that is
pretty much the story that is
in the news.
And it's very hard, even when
they issue a correction, to go
back and change it.
And once it's reached the
public, it's really too late
to go out--
the public isn't going to be
interested in a story about a
mistranslation.
So, it's--
unfortunately, a lot of what
we hear in the news is
affected by the translator's
skills and by the
interpreter's skills.
So, we have a lot of examples
of that in the book.
And I was asked the other day,
well, do you have any examples
of people who mistranslated
those things on purpose?
[LAUGHS]
And I'm not--
I'm not able to go
and interview
the exact, you know--
maybe that's another book.
[LAUGHS]
But certainly we have plenty
of examples of that.
And I don't think that
most of those have
been done on purpose.
I think the job of the
interpreter is just so
difficult that a lot of times,
interpreters make mistakes.
And so that's often the result
when we see some of those
things in the news.
Yeah.
TALIA: Hi, Nataly.
Thank you very much, and
welcome to the Bay, and
congratulations on
the publication.
Can you talk a little bit
about the process of
collecting the stories and the
decision-making of what to
include and what not?
And also, whether this book
is going to be translated?
[LAUGHTER].
NATALY KELLY: [LAUGHS]
Leave it to Talia to
come up with two
really great questions.
So, as for how we chose the
stories to include in the
book, it was very important that
we picked stories that
would reflect a range
of human emotions.
So we were careful to make sure
that we didn't have too
many tear-jerkers, and too many
funny mistranslations.
We wanted to hit every emotion
that we could.
We also wanted to hit every part
of life that we could.
So we had stories about
translation of sacred texts
and religion, because we wanted
people to see how
translation affects their
spiritual life.
But we also have stories about
translation in mundane topics.
And things like MAC Cosmetics,
and Harlequin romance novels,
and Hallmark Cards, and Nescafe,
and all of these
kinds of things, you
know, products that
people use every day.
So we really did try to pick a
range of topics that would hit
many different areas of life.
And we also looked at the common
things that people like
to read about, even
in the newspaper.
The sports section, the food
section, the politics section.
Current events.
Lifestyle, arts, entertainment,
those kinds of things.
So, we tried to hit on basically
every aspect of
life-- as many as we could.
And I wanted to include a
section on science, but that
didn't seem that interesting
to the average reader.
[LAUGHS]
But we tried to include as many
as we possibly could.
As for whether or not the book
will be translated--
I've had lots of volunteers,
because I have lots of friends
who are translators.
This is really a question of the
publisher, and publishing
rights, and how that
all works.
So, basically, if a publisher
in another country wants to
publish the book in another
language, they have to buy the
foreign rights from Penguin
USA, which is the original
publisher, and then they can
commission a translation in
that language for
that country.
So I actually don't have
much control over that.
But what I do know is, the more
popular it is in the home
market where it's launched,
usually, the more interest
there is in doing translated
versions in other countries.
So my hope is that
that will happen.
But I also think it's going to
be a hard book to translate,
because there's a lot
of humor in it.
[LAUGHS]
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yes.
DAGMAR DOLATSCHKO: Yeah.
Dagmar Dolatschko with Peritus
Language Services.
Thank you for this
beautiful book.
This is great.
We need to get the word out
more about our profession.
But I have a question
which maybe you can
answer because of your--
all your insights with Common
Sense Advisory.
With this increasing amount of
volume, we're just buried--
[LAUGHS]
to use your word--
in content.
And the ever-increasing
price pressure.
Where do you see quality
going in translation?
And that people still
understand, like in any other
profession, they will get
what they pay for?
NATALY KELLY: Yes.
Well, we did a study in 2008
on quality, and how buyers
define quality.
And one of the very interesting
things that we
found was that quality was
defined slightly differently,
depending on who was buying.
And so buyers in the retail
sector, for example, told us,
it doesn't matter to us if the
product name is spelled wrong,
or even if the description
has a typo.
But if the numbers are wrong,
we have a major problem.
Because if we've advertised that
that product is on sale
for $199.99, and they get a
decimal point wrong, or they
get a number wrong, we are
out millions of dollars.
So for them, the way
they define quality
was accuracy of numbers.
So that was in the
retail sector.
In sectors like life sciences,
of course, every single thing
has to be perfect.
There has to be no room for
mistranslations, because human
lives are on the line.
And in the automotive sector,
it depends on the type of
content, of course.
But for some things, like
user-generated content, of
course, and certain help
content, it was viewed as
acceptable to use machine
translation, and to have some
disclaimer that this is not
perfect translation.
And that if you need a perfect
translation, contact us.
And if they'd get a certain
number of inquiries, they
would start to pay for
professional translation of
that with a human involved.
But the notion of quality--
because a lot of times vendors
of translation services will
talk about quality as if it's
just this one big thing that
can be defined.
And our research shows that it's
much more nuanced than
that, and that there are certain
purposes for which
different levels of quality
are acceptable.
And we've actually gone to the
trouble of defining different
levels of quality for different
content types in
some of our research.
So, the answer is, quality
depends on
who's doing the buying.
DAGMAR DOLATSCHKO: Thank you.
NATALY KELLY: Mm-hmm.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm interested to
follow up on what you said
about not everybody should be a
translator even if he or she
speaks multiple languages.
So, who should be
a translator?
And what characteristics does
that person need to make that
successful?
NATALY KELLY: Mm-hmm.
Well, the reasons that
translators--
or would-be professional
translators and interpreters--
fail exams are different
depending on if we're talking
about translation
or interpreting.
But from an interpreting
perspective--
because that's--
I have actually graded exams
for interpreting.
I can say that the reason that
they typically fail is because
they haven't worked enough
on interpreting skills.
So, memory length.
Being able to remember the
information and transfer the
information without losing
information.
Or transforming it.
Because that's another thing
that sometimes interpreters
will accidentally just change
the meaning or forget
something, or they mishear
something.
They don't comprehend
properly.
And so they say something
different than what was
actually said.
So, that's the reason
that people fail a
lot of those exams.
A lot of it is lack of
preparation, lack of training,
and lack of practice,
lack of skills.
Not everybody has the skills and
has the ability to retain
large segments of information
and transfer them.
And some people simply lack
the language proficiency.
Because you might be fluent
in two languages, but that
doesn't mean that you can
be, for example, a court
interpreter.
If I ask you to say
"arraignment" in another
language-- even if you speak
that language, you can talk to
your friends and family--
you might not know how
to say arraignment
in that other language.
So, part of it is lack of
terminology knowledge, and
specialist terminology
in particular.
So, that's the reason
that a lot of
interpreters fail exams.
In the case of translation,
it's quite similar.
Sometimes it's making mistakes
with transferring meaning,
sometimes it's not knowing how
to use the appropriate
resources to research
terminology, and not knowing
how to apply tools, or use
tools in the case of some
exams, depending on who's
doing me the testing.
So there are a lot of reasons
why translators and
interpreters will fail.
But I would say the biggest
reason is because they
overestimate their level of
ability to manipulate the
language and to really go deep
in terms of terminology and in
terms of understanding in
a specialized area.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
thank you, Nataly.
NATALY KELLY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE].